freunde der sonne ich stoße an meine
grenzen bzw ich habe jetzt meine grenze
erreicht
ich wäre euch kurz darüber aufklären wie
es mir körperlich geht es mir psychisch
geht und wie es mit mir weitergeht
fangen wir an mit bord der zehnte
schwangerschaftsmonat steht ins haus
weil sich das 100 ich wusste vorher auch
nicht dass es einen zehnten
schwangerschaftsmonat gibt genau
genommen bin ich jetzt in woche 36 von
40 und es ist nicht ungewöhnlich dass
babys auch mal zwei wochen vor dem
errechneten geburtstermin kommen das
heißt in woche 38 und das heißt skating
ihre freunde in meinem bauch liegt
gerade ein mensch steht war 45 cm lang
und etwa zweieinhalb kilo schwer ist
wenn ihr euch jetzt sind ja das ist ja
schon so ein bisschen extra gewicht dass
man damit sich rumtragen muss holt mal
fruchtwasser gewichtszunahme beträgt
über die gesamte schwangerschaft
durchschnittlich 9 bis 14 kilo
unterliegt jedoch großen individuellen
schwankungen jetzt freunde ich habe
bisher 17 kilo zugenommen und ich bin
nicht groß dabei mache ich momentan so
viel sport laufen socken anziehen
aufstehen
mit der geburt wird man immerhin
schlagartig schon mal fünf kilo los das
geht auf fruchtwasser baby und plazenta
und man wird danach auch dieser
wassereinlagerung los sieht man vor
allem an händen und füßen ich habe die
ziemlich stark habe ich in meinem
erhöhten östrogenspiegel zu verdanken ja
meine babys habe ich jetzt schon auf
maximale breite gestellt und so sieht
das übrigens aus wenn ich versuche
meinen ehering anzuziehen außerdem habe
ich derzeit circa 40 prozent mehr
blutvolumen als vor der schwangerschaft
das heißt mein herz macht auch sport das
schlag volumen des herzens kann sich
unter geburt also wenn es dann richtig
losgeht von vor der schwangerschaft
circa 4 liter pro minute auf bis zu zehn
liter pro minute erhöhen
respekt außerdem ist mein herz gerade
quer das uterus wachstum führt über
einen 12
hochstand zu einer querlage des herzens
wtf so viel zu den wichtigsten
körperlichen updates psychisch geht es
mir ziemlich gut
also ich bin extrem ungeduldig ich kann
kaum was anderes mehr denken als an
dieses kind ich könnte den ganzen tag
damit verbringen irgendwo rumzusitzen
mit den händen auf dem bauch und mich
treten zu lassen und komischer weil sie
je näher die geburt rückt desto weniger
angst habe ich auch vor dem ganzen
schmerzen das haben schon so viele
frauen hinbekommen
wir kriegen das auch hin das einzige
worüber ich mir so ein bisschen gedanken
mache ist tatsächlich meile eigentlich
sollte man jetzt nicht an die arbeit
denken aber bei lab ist ja auch mehr als
arbeit also dieser kanal ist ja auch
mein baby ja ich hab den ja von klein an
großgezogen my life ist meine
leidenschaft er also es ist freude es
ist überzeugung ist herzblut aber jetzt
bin ich halt einem punkt wo ich keine
videos mehr machen kann und wenn das
kleine erst mal auf der welt ist dann
erst rechtlich zumindest für eine weile
ursprünglich war der plan dass ich ein
paar videos vor produziere die wir dann
während meiner babypause hier
veröffentlichen können aber wir haben es
einfach nicht geschafft hätten es
geschafft wenn wir videos mit weniger
recherche und produktionsaufwand gemacht
hätten
aber das wollte ich nicht also unser
rechercheaufwand ist seit unserer team
vergrößerung durch last nun größer
geworden und dass sie auch gut denn ich
will euch hier das wissenschaftliche
niveau liefern wofür ihr wahrscheinlich
abonniert habe der produktionsaufwand
ist größer geworden wenn man jetzt so
zurück schaut sieht man das hoffentlich
auch an der qualität der videos aber die
videos sind natürlich auch länger
geworden und dreh und schnitt mache ich
halt immer noch alleine und deswegen 70
hier in woche 36 wir haben kein einziges
video auf halde
und wir haben eine monatelange pause vor
uns in der ich natürlich auch keine
schwangerschaftsvertretung habe oder so
und dieser gedanke ist natürlich so ein
bisschen scary ihr wisst ja youtube
algorithmus man sei ja eigentlich keine
längeren pausen machen
also man fragt sich natürlich schon ob
man durch so eine monatelange pause all
die harte arbeit die wir die letzten
jahre hier reingesteckt haben und man
sich die einfach zunichte macht weil man
dann in youtube dummel völlig untergeht
selbst wenn ihr nächstes jahr unbedingt
unsere videos wieder gucken wollen wenn
wir dann wieder da sind kann es sein
dass sie von youtube gar nicht angezeigt
werden und er ist gar nicht mehr
mitbekommen aber ihr könnt uns
unterstützen wenn ihr möchtet also ich
frag ja sonst selten nach abos nur wenn
ihr jetzt wirklich gerne mal meine
schaut aber uns noch nicht abonniert
habt könnt ihr das gerne nachholen und
dann und das geht es raus in alle
abonnenten die glocke drücken dass auf
diesem kanal noch nie gesagt aber ich
das ist jetzt wirklich bei dem moment wo
sich lohnen würde das kind seine
gesundheit meine gesundheit das geht
jetzt erst mal vor davon möchte ich
alles abhängig machen
aber deswegen kann ich euch nicht sagen
wann er wieder was von mir hören werdet
vielleicht gibt es mal ein update in ein
zwei monaten vielleicht hörte erst in
drei monaten wieder was von mir
vielleicht erst in vier monaten aber
wenn ihr die glocke gedrückt habt dann
kriegt ihr eine notification dann haben
wir alle eine chance dass unser comeback
nicht an euch vorbei geht hin so viel
wie ich auch noch sagen wir kommen
nächstes jahr auf jeden fall wieder und
zwar wie freunde der sonne stockt schon
mal ein tief vorrat auf ihr habt mir
noch mehr verstärkung holen wäre
nächstes jahr in der team- vergrößerung
starten und ganz ganz vielen neuen ideen
und ich glaube eigentlich dass diese
zwangspause dem kanal langfristig gut
tun wird weil dann werden wir noch mal
richtig power haben um euch einfach noch
besseren content zu liefern also wenn
ihr uns über die pause hinweg helfen
möchte dann ist jetzt die devise
abwarten tee trinken und ganz einfach
zurück einfach die decke
ihr habt nichts zu verlieren
[Musik]
einfach die glocke denn meine ist gut
fürs geht der alkohol wird uns
ignorieren
damit dankeschön
auf wiedersehen
drückte einfach die glocke
also freunde der sonne was darf ich auch
ich werde das hier sehr vermissen aber
wir sehen uns auch bald wieder und bis
dahin ihr wisst bescheid sicher